it's 60 bucks or something like that and
you know and then they appreciate that
for me but then I wasn't gnome so then
we went to this town called the Atmore
Alabama
um and they
it left me there
so I I was stuck by myself at the um
at the gas station
and I got arrested
and then
um they they took me in jail
um in Atmore and
um
enough in out more Alabama they'd lock
you up
all by herself
all by yourself
and all I feed you is Popeye's Chicken
every day and you're not allowed out
there's no like general population
there's no going outside or nothing like
that
and they they did that to me and you
know
and they kept me in there for uh about
10 days
and then I got out and I went back to
the same [ __ ] gas station where I got
arrested up
doing the same [ __ ]
and they arrested me again
and uh it just gave me two more days but
then they told me that the
the magistrate which is basically like
the clerk of court he told me that
um I was
they dropped all my charges
so that's not bad yeah that's all right
I feel like I got I feel like I got
blessings you know train happens a rough
life
yeah it's not it's I mean it's not that
easy you know
how long you been doing it
I just learned how to hop trains about
um
a couple years ago
but I've been traveling for
um
I've been traveling for all my for about
10 years and
um if you want I could tell you I could
tell you how I started traveling yeah
you left home at what age
I wasn't about leaving home it was about
moving to California to becoming a rock
star
with my brother
and
I went out I went out there I brought
him I brought them all to California
where are you from
I'm from Orlando Florida
but um I I brought my brother out there
to uh to California
and I actually had a girlfriend at the
time but um
so when we moved when we moved out to
California we started a really cool band
our band's name is karuna which means
compassion in Sanskrit
and
um
that's my train Hopper name these days
too it's actually a really cool names
but um anyways so
um
I went out there with this girl named
Nicole but um I dumped
um we all got a a apartment together and
then um
we started this band and all that and
then this um this guy
they were like they were like our
producers or something and then he um he
looked at me in the face and he was like
hey I got this girl and she's a dancer
and she needs somewhere to stay and I
and I I told him that's fine she can
come stay at my house
but as soon as she came I felt deeply in
love with her
and and then she she taught me how to
travel from there and she showed me that
she lives in a in a Volkswagen bus
and she took me all over up and down the
west coast and
then she lost her mind
and she told me that
um yeah she she literally lost her mind
and I it was like what the [ __ ] you know
like how how are you gonna
how are you gonna lose your mind like
that
all of a sudden
and then she sold her fan to the Hari
Krishna Temple and I was really confused
so and that was the end of the band
huh that was the end of the band that
was the end of the band so then we had
to walk around and that's how I learned
how to be like
on the streets I'm sure
I'm sorry what was your childhood like
your parents
I come from a lot of money
I decide to live this way
yeah
how old are you
31 31. yeah your brother's on the
streets too
nope none of my family's on the streets
just you
I'm the only one
and uh I love my family I love my family
so much but
so what is it about that lifestyle
of having some wealth that uh doesn't
work for you
I just can't I can't I I just can't I
can't
um be happy
working a job
doing nothing like
just it just it doesn't work for me
and I I care I care you know like
maybe maybe you know my mom begs me and
my brothers begged me you'd probably beg
me you seem like an upright kind of guy
you know but like I can't I can't I
can't I can't do it no more you march to
A Different Drummer
or drugs a part of your life
no I only drink beer smoke cigarettes a
little bit a week
um they're not heroin or nothing like
that
you've been in New Orleans for how long
three days
you're just train hopping you you landed
yeah you landed here oh yeah yeah no I
was going to tell you about the train oh
did I I already told you about transfer
no tell me
maybe in the car you do I did in the car
yeah but not on the camera yeah so
I was in the there was this town in um
Oregon
it's called Eugene my daughter's there
they just legalize fentanyl there
which is pretty [ __ ] up they legalized
fentanyl um
maybe they just didn't
they're not Prosecuting it
as as harshly as they used to
it's literally illegal really I'm not
sure
my daughter's going to school there I'll
ask her about that
probably should
she's not doing that she's [ __ ] up
she's not doing fentanyl no sheep
I mean I didn't mean like that so so
you're you're in I'm literally in Eugene
dude and I'm I'm like look all right I'm
sitting on the street corner
and I'm I'm busking
Panhead bus or with a guitar oh basking
is uh playing music for money
yeah okay so
um spanging is
just asking people with the sign you
know like too ugly or that's what I fly
too ugly to prostitute
that's my favorite sign
but um I'm more of a busker I prefer but
I I my guitar broke in Chicago
and I have to go to Chicago too but
anyways what I was trying to tell you
was about Oregon
and um
yeah these kids they taught me how to
hop a train do all that and whatever and
um yeah I was I was out there in Oregon
and they the there's all these Tweakers
out there like literally it's it's legal
did you did you have any uh goals in
your life anything you wanted to do when
you were younger
I used to want to be a famous writer
Rockstar
Rockstar yeah for a long time I actually
did want to be a rockstar artist
I've always been Drawn to Art where do
you think you
inherited or learned this
this different path than your family
I don't know you know I gotta I gotta
tell you a secret
that's not really a secret but
I'm the only person in my family who has
curly hair
and I feel like it's kind of related
I don't really understand but
I think there's some sort of connection
are you misunderstood by most people and
your family I'm like an outcast yeah I
guess yeah you might you might have a
point there
you might have you might have I don't
think the curly hair has anything to do
with it no but I mean you're just why
are you different I mean
yeah
Dylan my name's Dylan
like Bob
and I'm the only one that's a [ __ ]
musician in the whole foot and now my
brother my brother is a really good
drummer actually
do you talk with your family still
yeah it's not my brother's house he's
the best drummer in the [ __ ]
but he always gets off time and like
he's pissing me up don't let him watch
this interview I I'm sorry Dustin he
does good you do get a little often but
you know I love you
what are you afraid of what do you worry
about now at this point in your life
um that's a deep question
I don't I don't know I don't think I'm I
don't think I'm really
I think that
scariest thing right now
because I've been traveling a lot
I'm scared of waking up dead
and it's a real concern
like like waking up and you
someone
either mugged you or robbed you or
killed did something and
that's that's that's pretty much what
I'm scared of
foreign
do you have friends
nope
I'm a single man I'm I'm alone
do you have any friends yeah I have some
great friends
I heard you on the phone it seems like
people care about you
where'd you like to be in five years you
want to be on the streets forever
are you happy
so I told you I lived in Oregon right
yep
and I used to grow pot
and I dated this this girl
um
School Bus
and I I fell in love with that kind of
Lifestyle
she was in a school bus she had she had
two kids
one was nine years old and the other one
was only three years old
um so like you know like I felt I fell
in love with this so hard and there was
this guy named Charlie and he uh he
taught me how to grow weed and and I
just I lived out in Oregon growing weed
and doing it doing all that
you know like
it's just I've been through so much life
experiences I don't even know what's
right anymore like I don't want I don't
wanna you know I don't ever go back I
don't want to ever go back to Babylon I
don't want to ever go back to just being
like a normal human being I don't think
it's right I don't think it's okay I
don't think that that's
the way that we should live
do you think Society has it wrong I
can't believe you I think it's all
[ __ ] up
[Music]
I I care I care you know like I do I
care so much you make it right
but like
what am I gonna do what am I gonna do I
got all these people telling me left and
right that the way I'm living is wrong
and
they know what's up but
I don't think they do
I'm sorry I know I'm being emotional I
didn't mean it I didn't mean it for it
to be like this
are you happy
in general
well
I'm happy when I'm on the streets that's
what I mean yeah yeah like I feel like
this is why I'm getting emotional
because I'm in this house but usually
I'm yeah I'm pretty happy you're cool
with
your decision to live this lifestyle
yeah of course
it's the only way to live for me
there was nothing in your childhood to
make you take this this ulterior my dad
left me when I started well my dad left
for me when I was three years old and he
just died
I'm sorry my dad just died
let's
um just a couple months ago actually and
he um but he left me twenty thousand
dollars so now I'm rich
where's your twenty thousand uh well I
was gonna take uh it's gonna take about
a month to my bank account
I don't know I don't mind
20 000 won't last long
no I won't
you ever get depressed or anxious or
angry anything like that
um no I'm not an angry person
I think I I might get a little you know
what you know what really bothers me is
dude this guy just tried to choke me out
at the uh in the uh
of a spot where you met me
over there at the um at the park
and this this guy just tried to choke me
out and he's literally he was he was
literally harming me
and I don't even have the guts I don't
the balls
to hurt him because I I don't fight I
don't
I can't I can't I can't
you're not a cruel person
I'm not a mean person and I can't
believe that I couldn't even
do that I can I can't believe I should
have
everything in your natural agents should
tell you to punch that [ __ ] in
the face or do something somebody step
in and do something
yeah someone had to
yeah this guy punched him right in the
face and made him all bloody dude
which is cool you know I don't I mean
what goes around comes around
I guess but like I should be able to you
know
it's like it's so weird that like I
couldn't even step up to the plate to
like
to fight this dude like it's literally
like
choking me out
over what
nothing he's just being a dick he's just
crazy he's just drunk or something
and I just
couldn't even [ __ ]
couldn't even [ __ ]
stand up because I can't because I
I feel I kind of feel like I'm a [ __ ]
well you're better off being a [ __ ]
than being like that
what being an [ __ ] being an [ __ ]
yeah
I know I got big fists yeah you got big
hands I do and you're probably [ __ ]
knocks somebody yeah I probably heard
them if you wanted to but you don't want
to like that's admirable
I don't know where this interview is
going
what's your biggest regret
well I did this
beautiful woman
it's mostly relationships every single
one of my relationships yeah we all have
regrets on not like not like I regret
being in them no but I regret losing
them the way you the way you handle
things yeah yeah yeah you're not living
a life if you don't have regrets like
that that's sort of my only regrets
and I'm so sorry like it's all my girls
yeah
that's that's that that's that'll pull
your heartstrings to ask me those kind
of questions of them really
oh you've been in love before
but at least once I love a lot
I love you though I love everybody you
know
that's how I feel
yeah all I got is love
I think you're I think you're good
people too that's that's why I'm doing
this there's only the long reason that
you saw me on the street
big crowd
I could have picked anybody in that
group but I picked you but you picked me
why'd you pick me I just use my I follow
my instincts yeah
I think but all those kids travel way
more than me
I might go back and pick somebody else
up too but really you were my first pick
yeah I'm glad you picked me thanks for
thanks for seeing me
there are there are uh other kids but
like none of them were not as nice as me
a lot of them are actually kind of mean
yeah and I think that's probably why you
picked me because well no I could see
that I was a nice guy I'll go back and
pick up somebody mean too oh you want a
meme kid that didn't stop me don't
they're not kids those are people in
their probably 40s and no but they're
that we we call each other we call each
other kids dirty kids is it is part of
this is you just don't want to grow up
is part of this this lifestyle being
that you just don't want to grow up
and pay taxes and have a job and
pay rent and all that stuff I just don't
think I want to subscribe to um
to the [ __ ] society that they're
trying to feed us I don't think it's I
don't think it's necessary
I don't think that's
um the answer I don't think that's the
answer and I don't think that's what
we're
we're not supposed to live that way
that's not that sounds like the only
choice that you've got conforming is not
the way to happiness no not the way
respect I think we're revolutionaries I
think the the reason that like I love
the way I live a lot of people that I
the only people that I hang out with
I think that's why we do what we do
because we're revolutionaries you're
free thinkers
Free People
and we don't
we don't need we don't need your [ __ ]
nine to five [ __ ]
don't remember you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
in your life
be quiet
and just listen
because you could talk talk talk
but until you start listening to what's
actually going on then you won't even
know
I meditate so that's that's what I
that's what I learned I'm I'm a yogi so
that's the our manifestation law of
attraction
yeah but like seriously
tell me a little bit about train hopping
it's dangerous right
um
just don't walk on the knuckle
don't walk on the knuckle what happens
if you walk on a knuckle it will eat
your foot at a literally like if you
like sellers like where the
it's like a kind of like a hitch where
they're connected and if you put your
foot there when the slack
so the slack is like um
when the train starts to go it does this
weird thing it's like
it's [ __ ] intense
but if you have your foot on that
knuckle
when the slack goes
it will eat your foot and um I I've met
a lot of kids that I have lost their
their whole foot from that kind of [ __ ]
um but no that's not the most dangerous
part the most dangerous part about train
run
is probably
um
I did meet this one guy I met this one
guy and um where was I I was in Green
River I would think I was a Green River
to hop out and come into the sky he was
older
it's probably like he was probably like
in his 50s he just like I jumped off the
freight train
backwards
so if you are gonna if you are gonna hop
off the freight train
and you want to go you want you want to
get off while it's moving
run in the same direction that it's
going
do not just hop off
so if it's going this way
all right here's the train if it's going
this way
you step off the ladder and you just run
as fast as you can in the same direction
that's moving
but my friend told me that he had gotten
off
the other way and he busted his whole
face and he got [ __ ]
you know that's kind of scary
I don't I don't mind
is there anything you miss about living
a
a normal life
I was watching movies and having
girlfriends
it's hard to it's hard to do that kind
of stuff nowadays yeah
do you think you'll ever go back
and about it because I when I just got
incarcerated in Alabama
it really made me think about [ __ ] and
um
I don't I don't think I can though
like I was telling you about the
Revolutionary [ __ ]
I don't I don't think that my soul will
ever agree with
being
subscribing to
[ __ ]
anymore this is in your blood
because I care
you know like I don't know if you ever
heard about
uh I don't know if you ever heard about
Jesus complex
tell me about that
see you you know who Jesus Christ is
right right like the Bible and all that
stuff right
why do you think he thought he was one
man who thought he was the son of God
aren't we all
I think we are
and I think we should all live that way
and I think that people that decide that
they're just gonna succumb to the
[ __ ] of some sort of like what
democracy or some sort of like
I don't I I don't know but like hey
I I think that
we should all live
as Jesus did or as Krishna did
I don't know just be the best version of
yourself that you could ever be whether
that be a religious or political or I
don't know man just do whatever it takes
man just be be yourself
and never settle for less and never take
[ __ ] from nobody
I heard I heard someone tell me one time
they said I'm sorry and I told them I
said don't be sorry
serious as [ __ ] don't take [ __ ] from
nobody and that's that's all I can say
that's all I can say
all right Dylan thank you very much